dans son magasin du centre ville
lyonnais
la créatrice de mode anne de l'aigle est
désormais bien seul
en 28 ans de carrière elle n'avait
jamais imaginé affronter une telle
situation
pour la première fois de sa vie elle
craint de devoir fermer définitivement
boutique à l'image de très nombreux
commerçants de la ville où aussi menacée
par la crise économique
on se retrouve avec la double peine
c'est à dire le problème de stock quand
toutes les boutiques
le stock donc de 7,6 verte et à écouler
et qu'on ne peut pas écoulé et en ce qui
nous concerne on a également le stock on
devait expédier aux boutiques y sont
fermées et qu'on ne peut pas expédier
plus le stock qui devait partir en
station à partir de fin novembre et les
stations étant également fermée on ne
pourra pas non plus écouler ce stock
donc ce stock nous coûte énormément
d'argent pour la créatrice les mauvaises
nouvelles s'accumulent de jour après la
noce dur confinement sont d'ailleurs lui
a envoyé en huissier de justice en
raison de ses loyers impayés
dos au mur elle a décidé il ya quinze
jours de créer un collectif pour alerter
les autorités sur la situation
désespérée des indépendants à lyon en ce
sens aujourd'hui délaissée par le
gouvernement bat il n'y a pas de miracle
à je pense sincèrement que le lien de
confiance avec le gouvernement ait rompu
c'est à dire qu'ils nous ont tellement
balader c'est exactement comme pour le
premier confinement on va de 15 jours en
quinze jours tout ça pour pas nous
annoncer que le confinement va durer
encore plusieurs semaines
ça sert à rien de nous vendre
vendre du vent on préférerait une forme
de franchise son collectif intitulé au
nom des indépendants a déjà rencontré le
préfet du rhône début novembre pour lui
faire part de ses revendications
une réunion qui n'a permis aucune
avancée significative des dizaines de
commerces ont déjà organisé des
rassemblements et prépare de nouvelles
actions de mobilisation pour la semaine
prochaine